le mar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en octobre 2015
après neuf longues années d'études jeu
devient officiellement glaciologue
j'y suis arrivé le rêve de toute une vie
mon diplôme j'obtiens d'une université
unique au monde
cette université elle se trouve entre le
nord de la norvège et le pôle nord
c'est l'université du spitzberg
mais pas le temps de faire la fête très
rapidement je suis appelé à partir en
mission scientifique
à l'autre bout de la planète du haut du
spitzberg
je pars pour l'antarctique l'antarctique
c'est carrément une autre planète
l'antarctique c'est le continent blanc
ces 23 fois la taille de la france
par endroits on y trouve jusqu'à quatre
kilomètres de glace pour nous les
glaciologues l'antarctique
c'est le graal absolu l'antarctique j'ai
passé deux mois deux mois à travailler
et à camper sur la péninsule et mon
travail c'était d'essayer de comprendre
avec mon équipe
à quel point les glaces de l'antarctique
sont sensibles aux changements
climatiques est assez rapidement on
s'est rendu compte que cette géante
calottes polaires de l'antarctique est
en fait une géante aux pieds d'argile et
vous savez ce que je retiens de ces deux
mois en antarctique
finalement c'est pas les paysages
extraordinaires qu'on a eu l'occasion de
voir là ou si peu de femmes et si peu
d'hommes où il a chance d'aller
finalement ce que je retiens c'est pas
non plus les tempêtes qu'on a essuyé les
unes après les autres
ces tempêtes qui nous ont bloqués dans
nos tentes plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines à la fois ce que je
retiens c'est
non plus les résultats scientifiquement
a récolté qui nous ont permis de publier
dans des journaux scientifiques très
très coté mais c'est pas ça du tout que
je retiens ce qui m'a le plus marqué ce
qui m'a le plus choqué est ce que j'ai
un rapport à ces deux mois en
antarctique
finalement c'est mon empreinte carbone
pour aller en antarctique c'est pas
anodin
croyez-moi partir en antarctique avant
quand on y allait on partait pour
plusieurs années on partait à envoyer on
savait même pas quand est-ce qu'on
allait rentrer c'était l'inconnue totale
et moi je partais en antarctique pour
deux mois et je partais en antarctique
depuis le spitzberg en avion alors il
m'a fallu beaucoup de petits sauts de
puce pour y aller du svalbard le
spitzberg à trousseau tromsoe oslo oslo
londres londres
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique santiago
santiago tout le tas arenas et là c'est
pas fini on a un corps pris d'autres
avions pour aller jusque sur la
péninsule antarctique et une fois sur
place pour pouvoir se déplacer
nous avons parcouru des centaines voire
des milliers de kilomètres en scooter
des neiges et pour pouvoir recharger nos
instruments
on a utilisé des générateurs électriques
et tout ça mis bout à bout ces neuf
tonnes de co2 alors 9 tonnes de co2
c'est ce qu'ils aimaient un français
moyen en un an
et moi en deux mois j'avais pulvérisé
mon empreinte carbone
neuf tonnes de co2 c'est à peu près 40
mille kilomètres parcourus en voiture
c'est vraiment ce chiffre là qui m'a
permis de me rendre compte que malgré
tout l'attachement toute la passion que
j'ai pour ces glaciers mais finalement
moi aussi je participer activement à les
faire disparaître
parce que chaque avion chaque
hélicoptère
jacques brise-glace que nous les
scientifiques on utilise pour aller
toujours un petit peu plus loin toujours
un petit peu plus haut pour récolter les
meilleures données possibles mais
finalement nous aussi
on est coupable de cette crise
climatique
mais face à ça je me suis dit ce n'était
pas le moment de baisser les bras bien
au contraire ce que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai monté une équipe ensemble nous
sommes les sentinelles du climat climate
sentinelle de mon équipe
nous sommes quatre femmes quatre
scientifiques il y as alia qui est
professeur en sciences environnementales
aux états unis il y as il ya qui et
glaciologue elle aussi basée en norvège
et dorothée glaciologue basé en suède
ensemble ce que nous allons faire c'est
nous allons tenter de montrer un nouveau
visage des sciences polaires on veut
montrer que la science elle peut être
beaucoup plus respectueuse de son
environnement et surtout que la science
elle peut être plus ouverte plus
accessible et pour ça l'année prochaine
au mois d'avril
nous allons repartir là où tout a
commencé
on va retourner sur l'île du spitzberg
mais cette fois on va pas faire la même
bêtise on va montrer que notre chance
que nos expéditions peuvent être les
plus décarbonés possible en avril
l'année prochaine on va vraiment aller
au delà de notre zone de confort ce
qu'on va faire c'est parcourir 500
kilomètres entre deux bases
scientifiques et on va pas y aller
n'importe comment on va y aller en ski
avec derrière nous ce qu'on appelle une
poule k c'est un traîneau qui aura tout
notre matériel de survie et tout notre
matériel scientifique le terrain qu'on
va parcourir
c'est un paysage absolument
extraordinaire
le spitzberg c'est un petit peu comme si
vous preniez les alpes bio vous les
mettez dans l'article ce sont des terres
qu'ils sont recouvertes à 60% par les
glaces
ce sont des terres dominée par la neige
les glaciers la banquise
c'est un terrain qui
physiquement est extrêmement difficile
alors c'est sûr qu'on aurait pu choisir
la facilité 1
on pourrait partir en scooter des neiges
on pourrait partir d'hélicoptères ça
serait plus simple vous avez bien
compris que c'est pas notre objectif
on pourrait aussi prendre avec nous des
chiens de traîneau après tout c'est une
grande tradition norvégienne
mais pour 4 personnes pendant un mois il
nous faudrait une vingtaine de chiens à
nourrir deux fois par jour vous rendez
compte la quantité de croquettes qu'il
faudra transporter environ 200 kilos
donc ça non merci on partira au mois
d'avril et c'est le mois d'avril c'est
pas par hasard
imaginez le mois d'avril au spitzberg
c'est un moment très particulier dans
l'année parce que il fait jour 24 heures
sur 24
et pour nous ça c'est très important
parce qu'on veut pouvoir scanner le
paysage tout autour de nous de jour
comme de nuit parce que les habitants
principaux du spitzberg c'est quoi ce
sont les ours polaires exactement et on
va là-bas chez eux on veut surtout pas
les déranger donc de pouvoir voir tout
autour de nous c'est très important
au mois d'avril on espère vraiment qu'il
fasse froid on veut qu'ils fassent le
plus froid possible parce que ça va
vraiment facilité notre progression
les températures vont être entre à peu
près moins 20 et moins 5 degrés mais ce
qui se passe là haut sur l'île du
spitzberg à cause du changement
climatique
les températures sont complètement
bouleversée cette année j'y étais déjà
en mission en quelques heures à peine
on est passé de -20 à + 6 degrés et ses
températures positives se sont maintenus
tellement longtemps que tout le paysage
autour de nous c'est fonderait tout et
de glace donc tout est très sensible à
ces températures positives parce que le
spitzberg aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'épicentre du changement
climatique
le spitzberg se réchauffe ses six fois
plus vite que le reste de la planète
alors notre expédition ça va être un
défi sportif évidemment mais surtout un
défi scientifique ce qu'on valait
mesurer là haut c'est quelque chose qui
ne tolère pas la moindre pollution de
notre part ce qu'on valait mesurez vous
savez ce sont ces petites particules
fines de pollution on en parle beaucoup
parce qu'elles sont très mauvaises pour
nous mais ces particules fines elles
sont aussi très mauvaise pour
l'environnement c'est de la suit elles
sont tellement fines qu'elles peuvent
voyager sur des milliers de kilomètres
ces petites particules ce qui se passe
qu'elle traverse les frontières et elles
peuvent aller des pays émetteurs jusque
dans l'arctique est ce qui se passe et
qu'au bout d'un moment
ces petites particules qu'est-ce qui se
passe elle retombe quelque part et
lorsqu'un retombe sur des surfaces qui
sont noirs on se rend pas vraiment
compte
mais si elles se déposent sur de la
neige ou de la place sur des paysages
immaculés
tout change ce qui se passe c'est que
les glaciers sont noircis la neige est
salie
est ce le rôle de l'article aujourd'hui
ne marche plus parce que l'article vous
savez c'est le miroir naturelles de
notre planète
parce qu'il est blanc et si on perd
cette couleur claire de l'article et ben
finalement l'article se met à fondre et
c'est ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui que
si l'article font aussi rapidement au
qu'aujourd'hui c'est à cause en grande
partie de nos activités et de ses
particules fines et vous savez ici à la
rochelle
on est à quelques mètres à peine du bord
de mer l'article vous paraît sûrement
très très loin mais finalement l'article
il est là nous sommes dire est
intimement liée à l'article
par l'océan donc une fois nos
échantillons récoltés sur nos 500 km on
va aller bien au delà de notre travail
de scientifiques habituelles parce que
vous savez en tant que scientifique tout
ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est de
récolter
analyser et publiés dans des journaux
scientifiques
alors je sais pas si au quotidien vous
avez souvent l'habitude de feuilleter
quelques pages du journal of life uk
john rogers physique au risque peut-être
science plos one another day sur le dgi
proceedings of atmospheric and chemical
senses peut-être je me doute que c'est
pas votre lecture quotidienne et c'est
notre rôle aujourd'hui en tant que
scientifique d'aller bien au delà de
cette publication là il faut rendre la
science intéressante expliqué à toutes
et à tous ce qui est en train de se
passer là haut dans l'article et pour
nous les sentinelles du climat ce qui
est très important c'est surtout d'être
aux côtés des jeunes générations
parce que ces jeunes générations
si on ne fait rien aujourd'hui ce sont
celles qui risquent de subir les plus
fortes conséquences du changement
climatique
c'est pour ça que nous sommes associés à
des écoles du monde entier dont fénelon
notre dame ici à la rochelle
nous sommes là pour soutenir ces jeunes
pour leur communiquer l'entousiasme de
la science et surtout leur faire
comprendre qu'il n'est pas trop tard
pour agir
il est important mais il faut prendre
cette dimension pleinement
hier j'étais encore à madrid à la coop
25 et je peux vous dire que chaque jour
quand je rentrais dans les bâtiments de
la conférence du climat je me disais que
ça y est ça y est il faut y croire
ça va être aujourd'hui que tout va se
passer
enfin on va comprendre la dimension du
problème et on va arriver tous ensemble
à résoudre ça et croyez moi tous les
jours quand je quittais les ports de la
coop va finalement il s'était rien passé
parce que l'espoir il n'était pas dans
les bâtiments de la coop l'espoir ils
étaient là ils étaient dans les rues
ensemble quand on a marché pour le
climat vendredi dernier nous étions cinq
cent mille jeunes scientifiques aux
côtés de greta solberg
et tous ensemble on marchait ont défilé
on criait noble anne hathaway noble anne
hathaway noble à la tab est notre
planète avait pas ce qu a pas de planète
b
et ça c'est crucial de le comprendre
aujourd'hui pour arriver tous ensemble à
faire face à cet immense défi climatique
finalement on n'y arrivera pas en
attendant qu'on prenne une décision pour
nous on n'y arrivera pas en attendant
qu'une technologie miraculeuse soit gré
on y arrivera seulement lorsque l'on
comprendra qu'on est tous dans le même
bateau et que c'est en travaillant tous
ensemble qu'on y arrivera que ce soit
nous les scientifiques qui sortions de
notre zone de confort qu'on travaille
ensuite avec vous les industriels avec
vous les collectivités vous les jeunes
avec vous les gouvernements c'est tous
ensemble qu'on pourra y arriver et tout
comme nos petites particules fines
peuvent traverser les frontières
je peux vous assurer que nos émissions
des forts positifs eux aussi pourront
aller jusque dans l'arctique et les
glaciers n'attendent plus que nous je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]